I sat down with a man named wal High who
was convinced to chop his penis off
after your community told him that there
was something wrong with him because he
had confusion why was he trans because
he was molested when he was four years
old by his uncle rather than being sat
down and spoken to by a psychologist he
was handed hormone pills and he
eventually chopped off his penis rates
go up after they transition after they
transition and Candace Owens wasn't the
one that chopped their dicks off the
truth is she's not actually spitting
anything hateful she's not
proclaiming anything hateful towards
these people in fact a lot of people on
the conservative side of things are
acknowledging that these people need
help the problem lies in the fact that
in their Community they're saying this
is an identity thing this is just who we
are they almost want their mental
illness to be affirmed and that's why
they call it affirming care but it's
like is that really helping anyone when
you're affirming someone's mental
illness